ce soir notre performance est assurée
par océanerosemarie pour son one man
show la lesbienne invisible les feux de
la rampe dans le meilleur des mondes
pascal bon soir vous avez cette pagaille
pour vous répondre j'adore île
magnifique que pour moi c'est à moi
alors donc la lesbienne invisible et
jeudi alors je vais vous dire une chose
tout de suite comme ça ça va vous mettre
mal à l'aise et moi aussi
super parce que c'est pour moi le
meilleur spectacle que j'ai vu depuis
bien longtemps déjà les airs tous sexes
confondus
un spectacle 100% lesbiennes 100% gay
100% hétéro en gros je lutte pour tout
le monde même si à plus de femmes dans
la salle mais c'est partout pareil ce
n'est qu'une étape sur les gîtes d'étape
alors on semble combat oui jusqu'à mine
de rien il ya quand même dans ce
spectacle dont on va parler une volonté
militante
quand même vraiment fabricant a
d'ailleurs donné envie de parler de
saint ouen qui est venu assez
naturellement parce que c'était mon
histoire est que voilà j'ai envie de
faire rire les gens avec ça de changer
un peu les préjugés que les gens peuvent
avoir les clichés dans la tête de la
camionneuse
on les voit mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
plus de personnages hétéro finalement
dans le spectacle puisque je parle
beaucoup de la réaction des hétéros g et
hommes
non
si c'est vrai lui me
un vieil a tellement dit pas ce mois ci
à toutes les étapes c'est un peu le
parcours initiatique
depuis qu'on est tout petit tout on est
un petit peu travaillé on ne sait pas
par quoi
et grâce à barbie on apprend plein de
choses ça m'a remis un bon taux nets y
est parvenu à beaucoup d'importance dans
la barbie mardi est en fait militante
sans savoir alors chez eux alors il vous
dit rien
dans le spectacle quand on vous
interroge posait pas souffert
d'homophobie pensez-vous penseurs non
franchement j'étais très privilégiée
dans un milieu vraiment très cool par
rapport à ça et du coup c'est vrai que
j'ai pu vivre à cette homosexualité
assez facilement et voilà alors donné
mon public en a toujours mais après on
peut aussi voilà décider enfin dans mon
cas débat trop on est très vite sa femme
avant tout ça tout le monde vient voir
le spectacle où ils sont venus 40
chevaux chacun contents ils s'en
prennent plein la gueule tu adores
j'hallucine
parce qu'il ya des moments comme ça
qu'est serre
comprendre ce qui se passe et villages
par l'infection est aussi papa et ma
maman bull s'étaient tous deux parlé
devant son papa enfin ils sont pas trop
coincé donc ça va alors commencer reçu
parce que je sais que peut-être vous
auriez aimé rencontrer un peu plus
jeunes une c'est un endroit qui vous
aurait aidé mais en fait c'est comme ça
j'en suis venu à faire spectacle oui
mais c'est dingue toutes les lesbiennes
du parc qu'on connaît qu'on ne citera
pas ce soir voilà vous parlez d'une
chanteuse dont vous parlez pas
d'ailleurs des chanteuses par les gens
connus et non les femmes connues
lesbiennes le disent pas trop faim par
au moins cher là je m'en voulais pas
leur boulot êtes pas celles qui sont le
problème c'est que quand on ne dit pas
sous prétexte de ça ne regarde que moi
c'est ma vie privée en fait c'est quand
même une forme de micro bic et intégrée
quoi c'est à dire qu'on a tellement peur
de la réaction pour le père ne rien dire
donc quelque part le message derrière c
est lesbienne sais pas
mais c'est vrai quand et ados et les
thèmes les filles tu vas voir tout le
temps plein film est super amoureuse de
la crise et c'est toujours un mec il
enrage à sa meilleure amie quelques
années c'est à vous
ok il ya les autobus les poids lourds à
tout ça et revend encouragements on
applaudit
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous donc
comme je l'expliquais je suis aussi
heureuse marie une lesbienne invisible
alors une lesbienne invisible pourquoi
parce que les gens ont souvent un mal
fou à comprendre qu'on puisse à la fois
avoir envie de mettre des mini jupes et
des doigts une fille
enfin il ya des gens qui y croient
attention surtout les filles hétéros
les kits héros c'est un problème on sait
quand vous leur dites que vous êtes
lesbiennes les trois automatiquement que
vous allez tout en les mettant au kit je
sais pas tout à l'heure bien un comme si
les hommes voulaient mettre toutes les
femmes dans leur lancée par maints
exemples
et alors les filles feront une fois
qu'elles ont compris qu'on n'allait pas
forcément tombée folle amoureuse d'elle
un précepteur atroce déception la
finissent toujours par l'ozone genia
soit absolument que je te présente
françoise et marie jo elles sont
lesbiennes elles aussi je suis sûr que
vous allez vous entend alors je sais pas
juste il vous imaginez si nous les
lesbiennes à chaque fois pour rencontrer
des hétéros ou l'un disait marche de
genia faut absolument que je présente
françois et agnes ils sont hétéros ou
aussi je suis sûr que vous allez vous
entends l'art en général ça finit en
dîner et passionnant avec leurs copines
de 65 ans prof de peinture sur soie dans
la creuse rouge pour deux hommes
hétérosexuels il ya une question qui me
pose souvent
c est ce que vous voudrez lesbiennes
vous faites l'amour comme dans les films
pornos c'est normal je veux dire mon nom
un homme hétéro cortès qui voit deux
femmes couché ensemble mais c'est dans
les films pornos et dans les films
pornos les filles entre elles
qu'est ce qu'elles font elle s'excite
elle s'allume en poussant de petits
gémissements kouif mais ça c'est
seulement pour mieux préparer l'entrée
triomphante à 2 3 go trogoff
l'étalon cela avec son rôti de boeuf
entre les gens
ce golf qui pour l'instant les parts or
celui le moteur d'une porsche carrera a
couvert de cambouis et de sueur mais
stoner ne va pas tarder à venir
rejoindre les deux gourmands de la civ
eva et mathilda qui sont ici depuis
maintenant bientôt trois quarts d'heure
le bout des seins et du clitoris en
poussant leurs petits gémissements queen
ils n'en peuvent plus et vaima tiédeur
elles sont très excités oh oui oh le
président cité mais elles ne savent pas
comment se faire jouir
ben non on sait pas comment se veut
rejouer et c'est pour ça qu'elle est en
strophes et son gros engins qui viennent
enfin les libérer de cette folle
excitation d'antenne ne savent que faire
au moins ce travail ils stoppent leurs
gémissements kunis je vais défoncer le
tube but à aa à aa pour que tu m'aimes
encore pour que tu m'aimes encore
excusez moi il faut que j'y aille mars
saluant les gens voient syndrome arrêts
aux feux de la rampe pendant le neuvième
pour son spectacle lesbiennes à 12h20
merci encore
[Musique]